i love you but you need to wake up ari's
family pressures her to move back to new
jersey and she starts to have concerns
that binyum is back in ethiopia i was uh
was my friend
grieving
this could cause a whole different set
of problems for us plus she won't do
tour of the house okay smith's parents
officially move in with him and jenny
and let's summits mom tell it it's off
to a messy start
jenny jenny
well god damn man
if this isn't going the way exactly i
knew it would
hey 90 day fans fam it's melisia for
those of you who didn't see after last
week's emotional episode where binyam
opened up even more about not seeing his
son in two years he shared an adorable
picture of his firstborn on instagram
with a caption quote i miss him every
single day i can't wait to give him a
hug and kiss i can't wait to hear him
call me dad please pray for me you can
tell that binyam really felt the support
he received following that episode i
just wanted to acknowledge those out
there who might be feeling pain similar
to binyam and send you love
i hope everything works out in the best
possible way for everyone involved in
your situation
all right off my soapbox let's get into
the juice forget the tea keep it juicy
at the top of the episode ari was making
her way back to the u.s after being away
for over a year avi and i are heading
back to the us so avi can get his
surgery there
yeah we're going to see grandma and
grandpa
you're going to see america for the
first time
oh did you hear him you're going to see
america for the first time
what a smart boy
i have baby fever y'all so let's move on
from avi for now my baby's coming home
with the baby
yeah ari's mom and dad picked her up
from the airport here comes arie roman
come out harry's here
hi
[Applause]
and their reunion was sweet it's your
grandma do you recognize me from the
videos video time
i love you so much as they were making
their way to ari's sister's house where
her brothers are as well ari called
binyam to check in with him hi everybody
and although he made it clear that he
misses them
he seemed a little too happy for ari's
comfort what are you doing
i was
my friend binyam went on to explain that
he was hanging out with friends because
he feels like he has to do something to
avoid being bored and alone now after
the way he reacted to them leaving
ethiopia i can understand that his
thoughts were probably all over the
place but at the same time binyam
allegedly has a history of being
unfaithful according to his exes did he
cheat on you i think
and he even raised suspicion about his
faithfulness while ari was in ethiopia
and when vinnie he goes out he stays out
all night you know and i would be alone
with the baby it's very hard yeah so
if bennium wants to keep his family as
bad as he says he does hopefully he's
out here doing the right thing in the
past
being long distance has nothing good for
our relationship
i didn't really consider that fact when
i decided to come to the us for obvious
surgery
i'm worried that with avi and i so far
away this could cause a whole different
set of problems for us
[Music]
we love you all of us
he sounds better than i thought it would
be er
yeah i know
[Music]
all right fast forward to dinner aka
ahri's mini intervention my goal i mean
i'm i'm not gonna lie is to see if i can
convince you guys to come and be near us
ari's mom fessed up to her secret plan
to try to get ari to move back home and
her sister began to bring up some valid
points on why she should consider it
listen i love you but you need to wake
up like
you did your little thing you had the
baby initially
proud of yourself now you gotta get real
about life now it's all fun and games
he's still a baby he's still portable
school seems so far off but she's gonna
wake up to that fact you have to raise a
person a human being where do you want
that to take place and what do you want
for his life
true
although the u.s is far from perfect
although angela might think otherwise
i'm an american people sacrifice
everything to come here for the
opportunity which begs the question why
can't ari just bring bingham to the u.s
i know a lot of us are wondering about
that doesn't that seem like the best
option for everyone have you talked to
benjamin about this well this episode
aria revealed that she applied for the
k-1 visa seven months ago but due to the
pandemic she hasn't heard anything back
the embassy's closed so
i don't even know if they're still
working on the visas at this point she
also said that benny never liked the
idea of leaving ethiopia but she went
ahead and applied because she doesn't
know what can happen in the future
speaking of the future there's a lot of
speculation online about binyam's past
there are some reports that he's applied
for a visa a number of times to get into
the states while he was in a
relationship with his ex-wife and he got
denied because he lived in a third world
country
but once again that's speculation there
are also rumors that benny and ari are
currently in the states together now in
real time
but unless someone slips up and says or
posts something they shouldn't
we just have to wait to confirm what's
true it's a happy moment for us for you
guys to be here all right i quickly want
to touch on submits parents moving in
with him and jenny this was our first
day at the house and apparently the fact
that his parents even wanted to move in
is a good sign
his mom in particular wants to make sure
that jenny knows how to be a good wife
to an indian man which submit is excited
about that's what i want
but the moment submits mom sat down she
started noticing all the mess like most
mothers would yeah janae she said is
this a design this shows all of our
marks of our drinks
oh it only got worse as smith's mom made
her way into the kitchen and i'm not
gonna lie it made me wonder if jenny or
submit did that extra scrub
knowing that they're about to have
guests especially guests as important as
submits parents
nicolas
[Music]
can you bring the broom
i don't know where the broom is
you do not use the broom
the miss parents sure do know how to
throw some shade i don't know where the
broom is
because you do not use the broom
i don't know about you but before
certain people come to stay at my house
my eyes magically zoom into specks of
dust and dirt that for some reason i
just didn't see before and i turn into
miss clean miss clean even if i'm not 24
7 that day you're gonna think i'm the
tidiest person in the world she's going
through my kitchen and finding every
single thing wrong checking every corner
moving my stuff around making me clean
and sweet well god damn man
if this isn't going the way exactly i
knew it would i'm just pissed she's just
it's my kitchen
jenny might have been pissed but submit
was happy i'm happy to see the way the
house is getting clean i'm not saying
jenny i don't do a good job but
my mom is
asking her to do a better than whatever
she's doing i like it well next week
submits mom is going to continue to
school jenny but the language barrier
has jenny thinking that it's going much
better than it actually is
i can try
i'm nervous at every moment that i am
around smith's mother
but the vibe that i'm getting is
actually very positive
i even am seeing her smile
i think that we could actually be
friends oh jenny
i wonder how she's gonna feel watching
that back
all right 90 day fans fam make sure you
stick with e.t because we are covering
it all i will see you next time
[Music]
you